I am worthy of the abundance I seek I am
attracting abundance with my positive
thoughts and I am certain that it will
come my way
I am building the life of my dreams
my conviction and dedication help me
work towards my dream life I refuse to
give up regardless of all the obstacles
that come my way I will eventually live
the life that I am seeking
I am open to receiving Prosperity from
the universe the Divine is always
showering gifts and I know that what I
seek will be manifested for me
these earning money is an easy process
for me
I am finding new sources of income
opportunities present themselves to me
without having to seek them
I am getting the amount of wealth that I
want
my dreams are not unrealistic I am
slowly but surely achieving them
I am receiving money in expected and
unexpected ways I do not limit my
options and I can see my money
multiplied because of that
I am a money magnet my bank account is
overflowing with money for me to use
I am doing my job with Excellence so
that I can rise in my career
success comes to those people who always
give their best and work dedicatedly
I am certain financial success is in my
fate I can visualize a more prosperous
lifestyle
I am growing rich with every passing day
I am learning how to spend my money in a
more efficient manner
I am making wiser financial decisions my
knowledge is growing and I am learning
from the experts who help me make better
financial decisions
I am investing my money wisely I know
that even the most minor Investments go
a long way and I research before I make
any investment I can see this wealth
growing
I am investing time in learning from
people who excel at financial management
my knowledge of money matters is a
growing day by day
I am able to use money wisely
I have more than enough money to fulfill
my needs
I'm saving money
I refuse to waste my money on things
that won't benefit me in the long run
instead I choose to save that money
I am attracting wealth my way
I know that as I give generously more
wealth will come my way and that it will
enrich me internally and externally
I am living a prosperous life I have all
that I need within my reach and more
my wealth is also increasing and my
standard of living is improving
I am the master of my wealth money does
not control me but instead I control it
I know how to handle large and small
sums of money with ease
I am a strong and resilient person I
face all difficulties in life with
courage and I knock them down with ease
I am grateful for the struggles in my
life because they have helped me grow
I have learned important lessons because
of my struggles that I would not have
learned otherwise
I am not afraid of failure I allow the
failures in life to be the teachers that
guide me to improve and to rise as an
even better version of myself
I am still in the process of growth and
I will make mistakes
it is part of human nature to make
mistakes but after making them I will
learn from them
I am not defined by my mistakes my
mistakes are an element of the past they
have passed and they no longer have any
power over me
I am more than my past I have a
beautiful and successful future ahead of
me I will not let my past [ __ ] me
I am focused on building a better future
wise people do not let their mistakes
hold them back and I refuse to do that
too
everyone in life who has found success
made mistakes before they found their
success
I am walking toward the road to success
success is within my reach and if I work
towards it I am going to find it
I am committed to creating a positive
aura around me
I cultivate positive thoughts about
myself and other people around me
I am aligned with trust and conviction
these two elements push me and motivate
me when I feel down
I am releasing all my negative thoughts
about the future
my anxieties will not stand in my way I
release them and I replace them with
positive rejuvenating thoughts
I am kind towards myself and I forgive
myself for all my mistakes
as a human being I am allowed to err I
allow myself this grace of imperfection
I am walking on the road to
self-improvement
each day is an opportunity to become
better
I make sure to do something to improve
my social physical mental emotional and
spiritual being every day
I am sporty and Physically Active I take
good care of my mind and body I practice
clean eating and I am always conscious
of my food choices I meditate to ensure
my well-being
I am always moving up the ladder of
self-improvement and never down
I do not allow anyone or anything to
demotivate me
I am enthusiastic about self-improvement
I make sure that I take baby steps
towards Improvement to make it more
sustainable
I am responsible for my thoughts and
actions I fulfill all tasks given to me
with Excellence
I am getting better at fulfilling
commitments every day my punctuality and
productivity have improved and I have
learned from my mistakes
I am feeling happier day by day I try to
become at least one percent better every
day I know slow and steady wins the race
I am living life on my own terms and I
enjoy it wholeheartedly Nothing in life
holds me back I have all that I need
I am more confident every day I
challenge myself to be better than the
person I was yesterday
I am working on improving each aspect of
my life in being one by one I have a
clear picture of who I desire to be and
I know one day I will be who I aspire to
be every day I am a better individual
overall
I am cultivating peace of mind body and
soul my energy is not spent on worrying
I am meant to live a healthy fulfilling
life filled with joy and peace I
dedicate my energy to goodness and
positivity
I forgive everyone who has hurt me I do
not hold grudges and destroy my peace of
mind I forgive because I need the peace
not because they deserve it
I am the main character of my life's
story
other people are just supporting
characters
I give myself the focus all main
characters deserve I take care of myself
I am committed to helping my mind and
body heal my spirit deserves tranquility
and I will do what it takes to develop
peace
I am at peace with everything around me
little things do not bother me like they
used to and I dismiss all minor
inconveniences
I am empathetic toward other people I
allow myself to step into their shoes
and show them the empathy they deserve
I am completely relaxed my body feels
light and free from all worries as I
breathe I release all my anxieties
I am taking one step at a time
growth does not happen all at once it
takes time and effort
I am able to make decisions that guide
me towards peace I refuse to act
impulsively I think about my piece
before I take any action
I am surrounded by people that bring
peace to my life
I distance myself from all the toxic
people around me I choose to be around
people that exude peace
I am focused on the silver lining of
every dark cloud I know that everything
happens for a reason and there are
positive aspects to every situation
I am surrounded by a Serene aura
every cell in my body is attracting
positivity in my life
I am filled with peaceful energy people
enjoy my company because I exude peace
and Tranquility my body is completely
and utterly calm
I am nourished with compassion and joy I
give myself the love that I deserve and
I engage in activities that bring me joy
I am ready to heal from my past traumas
I allow myself to address all the
difficult emotions pent up inside my
body and then I slowly release them into
the air
I am able to relax in all situations
I do not let stress get to me
I have complete control over my emotions
and I know how to handle them
I am granted whatever I seek
I always achieve what I set out to
accomplish none of my tasks are left
unfinished
I am working towards success
it is not hard for me to achieve success
I deserve a successful life and a
successful career
I have easily reached where I want to be
in life
I am lucky in all aspects of my life
Miracles come my way every single day
I'm enjoying a life filled with ease and
comfort the universe has made many
things easy for me
I am a unique individual and this is
reflected in my achievements I have
achieved at least as much as the
successful people around me and although
my achievements are different My Success
is only relative to me
I did not compare myself to others
I am always optimistic about my future I
trust my fate to bring me the abundance
I seek I never let negative thoughts
spoil my life
I deserve all the goodness that fate has
to offer
I am cultivating more success
good things happen to me every day
no black cat crossing my path can ruin
my day
I have a plethora of opportunities
I am able to take advantage of any
opportunity that comes my way
I make the most out of every situation
which is why success and prosperity come
naturally to me
I am humble and dignified about my
success
I do not reveal any arrogance I have
mastered the art of humility so that
others respect me
I am able to conceive ideas that lead me
to success
I Believe In The Law of Attraction and
have mastered this phenomenon
I am confident in my power to positively
change my life by using the Law of
Attraction and manifestation I am in
control of my life and can always make
it better
I am ready to heal from my past traumas
I allow myself to address all the
difficult emotions pent up inside my
body and then I slowly release them into
the air
I am able to relax in all situations
I do not let stress get to me
I have complete control over my emotions
and I know how to handle them
I am granted whatever I seek
I always achieve what I set out to
accomplish none of my tasks are left
unfinished
I am working towards success
it is not hard for me to achieve success
I deserve a successful life and a
successful career
I have easily reached where I want to be
in life
I am lucky in all aspects of my life
Miracles come my way every single day
I am enjoying a life filled with ease
and comfort the universe has made many
things easy for me
I am a unique individual and this is
reflected in my achievements I have
achieved at least as much as the
successful people around me and although
my achievements are different My Success
is only relative to me
I did not compare myself to others
I am always optimistic about my future I
trust my fate to bring me the abundance
I seek I never let negative thoughts
spoil my life
I deserve all the goodness that fate has
to offer
I am cultivating more success
good things happen to me every day
no black cat crossing my path can ruin
my day
I have a plethora of opportunities
I am able to take advantage of any
opportunity that comes my way
I make the most out of every situation
which is why success and prosperity come
naturally to me
I am humble and dignified about my
success
I do not reveal any arrogance I have
mastered the art of humility so that
others respect me
I am able to conceive ideas that lead me
to success
I Believe In The Law of Attraction and
have mastered this phenomenon
I am confident in my power to positively
change my life by using the Law of
Attraction and manifestation I am in
control of my life and can always make
it better
I am able to attract all the things I
want in life with ease the things and
opportunities I want present themselves
to me without any difficulty
I am the creator of My reality
I design my life according to my
thoughts and desires
I'm always attracting positive things in
my life through a positive attitude I
constantly strive to raise my vibrations
through good thoughts words and actions
I am incredibly blessed and grateful my
gratitude allows me to acquire gifts
from the universe in abundance
I am able to visualize my best life and
I watch as it manifests I use my
imagination to conjure up my perfect
life and I bring it into reality through
my belief that will absolutely occur in
the future
I am making a worthy contribution to the
world and I am reaping its benefits in
my own life
none of my efforts of doing good are
wasted instead they manifest positively
in my life
I am able to think positively my
thoughts are optimistic and I possess
the glass half full mindset
I find each day has promise and purpose
and makes my life better
every day presents new experiences and
opportunities that I know are beneficial
to my growth as a person and bring
positive change to my life
I am certain I can get through any
situation in life
my obstacles do not leave me feeling
helpless and my strength helps me to
bear and surmount them
I am doing the best that I can
celebrating small wins while forgiving
myself for not achieving all that I had
set out to accomplish is important for
my mental health and overall quality of
life
I am able to block out negative and
harmful thoughts I have full control
over my mind and I choose the thoughts
that I allow to stay and those I reject
my mind has no room for pessimism or
doubt which leaves more room for
positivity
I am in control of my negative thoughts
and anxiety and I have the power to
change them
my mind is my own and I choose which
thoughts to entertain and which to
dismiss
I am able to trust the process of life
and where it takes me I acknowledge that
life is a journey and the difficult
times I am facing are not the Final
Destination but just a brief detour
along the way
I am able to forgive myself and absolve
myself of guilt
dwelling on my past mistakes is not
helpful instead I will show myself
compassion and move past them with Grace
[Music]
I am proud of all my accomplishments
large or small although I am not the
best version of myself yet I admire my
strength and determination to get
through all the rough patches of my life
I am able to trust myself and to make
the right decisions I fully trust my
intuition and believe that I can steer
myself away from harm and towards peace
I am living a rewarding lifestyle
every little thing I do in my life
brings me joy and gives me a sense of
fulfillment
I am becoming more self-aware I am
attuned to my emotions and I know what
affects me positively or negatively
I am proud of the person I Have Become
I have learned from my mistakes and each
day I become a better version of myself
I am unaffected by other people's
opinions
some people love to criticize for no
reason but I refuse to listen to them
and their opinions
I am worthy of the respect that I seek
respect is a basic right that should be
granted to people without asking I
refuse to be disrespected for whatever
reason
I am a respectable individual
I respect other people so it is only
natural for me to be respected I do not
need to change to be respected respect
is unconditional I do not need to change
to be loved
I am worthy of unconditional love
my soul mate recognizes me respects me
and acknowledges my efforts in our
relationship my soul mate likes me just
the way I am I am moving closer to my
soul mate day by day
I am loved unconditionally by my friends
and family and like everyone else I must
love myself unconditionally as well
I am prioritizing my happiness over
other peoples I have every right to
happiness and I understand that
happiness comes from within
I am working on a healthier lifestyle
and a healthier me to ensure my
happiness I find happiness in making
others happy too and it makes me smile
I am walking along the path toward
greater happiness
I hold the keys to my happiness and I
have unlocked the door
I expect to find the light of Happiness
even in the darkest of times
I am a rich happy respectable person
beloved by many other people are
inspired by my Zeal and the many
admirable characteristics that I possess
I am perfect the way I am
I do not need to change for anyone else
I am completely independent and
self-sufficient I do not rely on anyone
else to fulfill my needs I handle my own
affairs with ease
I am loved by the people around me
other people love my kindness and
compassion they love me for my passion
my courage my resilience and all my
positive attributes
I am constantly becoming a better
version of myself
I can see myself improving daily as I
learn from my mistakes
I am talented in many different ways
every day I discover a new skill that I
have and every day I have a new
achievement
I am capable of achieving all my goals I
have everything I need to build my dream
life
I am excited to see how far I can go I
have achieved so much in life and I am
curious to know where life will take me
I am releasing all fears and doubts
trapped in my body with every deep
breath I can feel my body relax as it
frees me from all my worries
I am in control of my life
everything is within my control my
emotions do not control me nor do other
people
I make wise decisions that will help me
in my present life and in the future
I am exactly where I need to be in life
my life is going in the perfect
Direction
I am filled with energy and motivation
to achieve all my goals every day I wake
up with a determination to do my best
and Achieve something new
I am able to balance work and relaxation
with ease taking time for rest is
important and I take time out for myself
whenever I feel exhausted
I am filled with Creative Energy I can
do things in a way that no one else can
my ideas are novel and unique
I am spending my time and energy wisely
my time and energy are valuable once
they are gone I can never get them back
which is why I spend them on the things
that will help me in the long run
I am the master of my fate my life is
not predetermined I am choosing the life
that I want
I am disciplined and remain on the right
track I do not get distracted easily
I am completely focused on my goals
I have laser sharp focus and I know
exactly what I need to do
I am the captain of the ship of my soul
I know my destination and although the
journey will be arduous I will navigate
through difficult storms when duty calls
my life is a worthy Adventure
I am capable of making the best
decisions I discuss my problems with the
right people I always take wise actions
without external interference I do not
allow casual observers to comment on my
situation
I am accountable to myself for whatever
I do
I Bear all consequences of my decisions
and actions whether good or bad I know
that it's not someone else's
responsibility to solve my problems
I am a responsible person
I do not burden other people needlessly
with my issues I deal with things on my
own
I am prepared to take risks when I need
to life is not just about playing safe I
must also move outside my comfort zone
in order to achieve new things
I am determined and dedicated I never
give up I never take the back seat
I am the only one who can change myself
or my lifestyle
I lead a practical life dealing with all
problems in stride
I am excited to make progress toward my
goals I have so much that I want to
share with this world and I am excited
to do that
I am aware of my health and other
aspects of my life I take care of myself
as best I can
I am always optimistic about my future
I know how to plan things like a pro
I am responsible for fulfilling my
dreams and aspirations I do not let
self-doubt hinder my plans I have
accepted who I am and I am working to
improve myself
I am surrounded by inspiring people I
look up to the people around me and
admire them I learned from their
mistakes so I do not repeat them myself
I am my biggest hero I Inspire myself to
do better improve and always be the best
version of myself there is no one like
me I am more than enough for myself
I am completely at ease
nothing bothers me I am free from all
insecurities
I am safe and secure
I do not feel threatened by anyone or
anything
is bothering me right now
I am viewing the future in a positive
light and I am excited about what it has
in store for me the future is no longer
a daunting idea for me but something I
increasingly look forward to
I am grateful for all that I have and
that adds to my blessings being grateful
produces a positive mindset and in turn
creates positive vibrations that attract
more goodness to my life